pero la reforma que se está planteando
actualmente de una reforma
imprescindible por dos razones la
primera porque chile es de los países
con menor carga tributaria no solo de la
ocde sino incluso a nivel de américa
latina alcanzando apenas al 18% del
producto interno bruto y la segunda
razón es de que los procesos sociales
sus últimos y en particular el acceso
del nuevo gobierno implica una serie de
responsabilidades sociales que hay que
financiar y reformas a la salud al
sistema previsional reformas en la
educación
mayor aportes para reducir la
desigualdad será imprescindible crear
una reforma de esta envergadura que
alcanza al cuatro y un punto
4.1 del producto interno bruto creo que
esa
es imprescindible es imprescindible y
como usted dice efectivamente hay un
impuesto a las grandes riquezas
planteados porque esta es una propuesta
reciente
de más de 5 millones de dólares hasta 14
millones de dólares que alcanzaría al 1%
y en aquellos patrimonios con cifras
superiores a los 14,7 millones de
dólares esa sería un impuesto de 1.8 por
ciento todavía es algo bastante modesto
hay que reconocer que no se trata de
nada que pueda significar
alguna transformación tan importante en
lo que es la estructura de desigualdad
de chile que va a persistir de todos
modos sí señor le quiero preguntar chile
es el mayor productor de cobre en el
mundo como tomarán las empresas mineras
el aumento de la tributación
pienso que esto probablemente es lo que
más ha conversado el ministro de
hacienda en realidad hubo muchas muchas
conversaciones con el sector público con
el sector privado digo tanto con los
empresarios como los trabajadores y
dentro de eso con el sector minero creo
que las conversaciones están bastante
avanzadas ahora quiero decir de que el
royalty que se está planteando es
bastante modesto es decir ahí por
ejemplo
la propuesta del gobierno está
dependiendo del valor del precio del
cobre y cuando llegamos a un nivel de 4
dólares la libra que todavía que es un
nivel alto por así si se considera el
promedio en la propuesta del gobierno es
apenas recaudar un 0.7 por ciento del
pib es decir no se trata de una
transformación tan radical del
del impuesto a la minería actualmente
creo que por eso no no pienso que vaya a
haber una reacción tan negativa del
sector cuprífero o privado